Hey EskimoPieLoves324b21, how hireable do
you think you are?
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
Once upon a time, in the early days of the
internet.
People used the platform to play around with
identity, you could be whoever you wanted
to be.
You could even be different people!
It was so much fun.
Sadly.. those days are gone.
According to researchers from the University
of Washington most people today say their
online persona and their offline self are
pretty similar.
There are a number of studies that show how
much first impressions matter.
One of the first things people see about us
online is our username or email address.
And man.
Does it matter.
Which means that how you present yourself
online, says a lot about you.
We concern ourselves so much with the big
parts of our online persona, like our profile
picture or our bio, yet a lot can be inferred
from something as small as an email address.
One study published in the Journal of Research
in Personality called “How extraverted is
honey.bunny77@hotmail.de?” found that people
are actually pretty good at inferring personality
from email addresses.
Researchers looked at almost 600 e-mail addresses
of young adults.
They collected data from personality tests
that judged traits like neuroticism, openness,
agreeableness, conscientiousness, and narcissism
and extraversion.
The researchers then asked 100 other people
what their impressions of those people’s
personalities were.
They found that most people’s impressions
were pretty much the same based only on e-mail
address alone.
Which you know, personality psychology is
a little controversial, but the study at least
showed there are certain stereotypes at play
with email addresses and those stereotypes
affect how people see you.
Which matters a lot when you’re trying to
land a job.
One study published in the journal Cyberpsychology,
Behavior, and Social Networking found that
your email address makes a difference when
applying to jobs.
It kind of sounds like a no-duh thing, but
there actually hasn’t been a lot of empirical
evidence to back it up.
73 professional recruiters looked at fake
resumes, the resumes had a mix of things like
spelling errors, different typefaces and informal
and formal email addresses.
The recruiters judged the applicants on intelligence
and the 6 personality traits I mentioned earlier.
The study found that a less than professional
email address like luv_u_sanne@hotmail.com,
was just as hurtful as spelling mistakes.
Even which email service you use says a lot
about you.
It could indicate how “tech savvy” you
are.
Mailchimp did a survey that found that gmail
and hotmail users tend be used by the young
adults with a median age of 31.
Yeah I know Hotmail is so passe to us in the
States… but it’s still popular by young
people abroad.
Gmail users use Google Chrome and like tech
stuff.
If you use a yahoo address you’re probably
around settling down age, like 34, you like
religion and maybe interested in recruitment
and staffing. (and you’re probably no fun
at parties) If your email ends in an AOL.com
or Comcast.com you might be in your mid 40s
and are interested in the finer things in
life like good food and gardening.
So whether we like it or not, our email addresses
say a lot about us.
So much science to learn, you guys!
So much I couldn’t possibly fit it all into
one episode.
Fortunately, we’ll have a chance to talk
MORE science on Thursday April 9 at 2 PM,
pacific 5 eastern.
That’s when we’re hanging out with Mitchell
Moffit and Greg Brown from ASAPScience and
Joe Hanson from It's Okay to Be Smart!
RSVP with the link in the description because
you do not want to miss it.